Now let me actually just recap for
a little bit.
So this is basically the 2D image
transformations we are looking at.
We have an object that
could be translated,
this could be the image itself.
We could scale it,
in this case I'm showing the scaling.
We could rotate it, an affine warp, and
a projective or
perspective warp would be this one.
So basically let's
summarize all of them.
I'm going to show this with
a simple kind of a table here and
of course we look at how we actually
want to do the transformation,
what the three by three looks like, and
what kinds of things does it preserve.
Of course, simple translation
two degrees of freedom, and
we know kind of how to
model this basically and
these are the two parameters we
would actually be kind of modeling.
And of course in this case you only get
translation, orientation is preserved.
Case if you clicked in where
there's a rigid transformation,
three degrees of freedom,
the object is rotated.
Here of course we would change if
there's translation involved in
these two values, but
also just the the cosine, theta, and
stuff like that would change
these four values here too.
This would still remain
one as it is here.
And, of course, zero, zero, zero, zero.
I'm not implying that
this would be a zero,
it just means that the cosines always
based on theta would be coming in.
In this case,
the lens would be preserved.
Third case similarity,
where now we have scaled things
out four degrees of freedom.
Basically what that means is now we
basically have the two parameters for
translation, assuming
there's translation going on.
And scale parameters would be here and
the rest would be the same.
For affine, we've looked at
this just in the quiz before.
Everything that would preserve,
a parallelism would be preserved.
Lines would be straight and
everything else.
We also know that the six parameters
here would be the ones we would need to
model and
that's the six degrees of freedom.
Projective eight degrees of freedom,
all of these.
This would be still one.
Straight lines are preserved,
parallelism is not preserved.
So if you notice as we down
this preserves orientation,
because it's only translation.
This doesn't preserve orientation, but
it preserves lens, but next time
all of the angles are preserved.
Parallel lines and lines are preserved
and only straight lines are preserved.
And if you notice this is
how we can go through and
look at different types of images from
starting here looking at translation,
rotation, scale, affine,
and perspec, projective.